salir de afganistán a toda costa con esa
consigna de algunas personas que
hicieron interrumpir el paso de un avión
militar estadounidense en el aeropuerto
de kabul algunos se colgaron de la
aeronave y posteriormente cayeron
y otros intentaron ingresar por una
torre de control o saltar los paredones
de seguridad escenas dramáticas que
desembocaron en algunos disparos y
situaciones de desorden con soldados
talibanes intentando controlar el caos
para algunos huir es la única
alternativa tras la toma de kabul
estamos aquí porque no tenemos trabajo
dejamos nuestros lugares porque no
teníamos comida más de 70 países
intentan evacuar a sus nacionales y
colaboradores una operación a
contrarreloj que refleja el fallo de
cálculo tras el retiro de las tropas
internacionales del país
el temor crece sobre todo entre aquellos
afganos que han ayudado a misiones
extranjeras
ahora mismo mi familia y yo vinimos a
kabul para estar en un lugar seguro y
estamos escondidos para mantener un
perfil bajo frente al talibán
y
estamos en peligro no sólo yo cualquiera
que ha trabajado para el ejército alemán
ellos y sus familias están en riesgo y
pido la posibilidad de evacuarlos y tan
pronto como sea posible
mientras tanto los talibanes intentan
dar una imagen de calma queremos
decirles que vivan con satisfacción y
siguen su rutina diaria como de
costumbre la gente de kabul no está bajo
amenaza el alcalde de la capital aseguró
que sigue en su cargo y que el talibán
aún no toma el control total de la
ciudad con la incógnita de saber cómo
será el nuevo régimen de los insurgentes
afganistán se debate entre la
incertidumbre y el miedo